there's something in your career that i
think howard really resonates with him
and howard's always like
i like how i always want to be a game
show host because like it just goes on
and on and in essence it's it's
syndicated oh yeah and you're in two
shows that are now syndicated and one of
the shows the goldbergs which i love
that to me that's the dream in the sense
like i always wanted to ask you're the
voice-over guy like like sagitt was and
how i met your mother yes like daniel
stern was in the warner years yes and is
that a do you go in like one day a year
and just do them all
i do a day a week they i had to you know
they work they actually work pretty hard
on those scripts so there's a lot of
like we just do one a week and then i'll
do
um adr like a couple days afterward just
for a couple lines but um yeah it's and
i have a little home set up so i can
just they call me up facetime me okay
here we go and half an hour i'm done
it's got to be the golden gig for you i
mean you have made your way into the mcu
universe
uh voicing animated characters yes uh
god i mean i'm i'm do i narrate the
goldbergs i'm matthew the raven in the
sandman i'm uh pip the troll on the
turtles i was modoc yeah i mean getting
to do voice-over is
the best it's so much fun what's
difference in your process uh when
you're standing in a studio behind a
microphone staring at your character on
the screen voicing it well a lot of
times you don't have the character on
screen a lot of times you're creating a
character that they will then draw or
render it's when you're doing adr and
that can be kind of nerve-wracking
because you go out of your way like what
was frustrating with i mean what's
interesting when i did ratatouille i
came in with a bunch of voices and they
went no no we want your voice do your
actual voice
um and same with matthew the raven i was
gonna do more of a like listen boss i go
no no just do your voice we wrote it
that way